من جهه اخرى اعلن حاكم مدينه في شبه جزيره
القرم الموالي لروسيا اعلن ان الدفاعات
الجويه اسقط الطائره مسيره في اجواء
المدينه اما فيدونياسك فعالنت السلطات
المواليه لروسيا ان القوات الاوكرانيه
واصلت قصف المناطق الخاضعه لسيطرتها
الليله الماضيه وصباح اليوم وقالت السلطات
المواليه لروسيا ان الجيش الاوكرانيه قصف
بالمدفعيه حيه
في دنياك وبلده جولو موف سكي ومدينه
جورلوفاكا واشارت كذلك الى تعرض مدينه
مكيف كالمحذيه لدنياسك لقصفين صاروخين
وقد اتهم رئيس الاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في منطقه الشرقيه هايدي القوات
المواليه لروسيا بخرق الهدنه التي اعلنتها
روسيا من طرف واحد واكد رئيس الاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه استمرار القوات
الروسيه في قصف المواقع الاوكرانيه على
اكثر من جبهه خلال الساعات الماضيه
لروسيا عدم التزامهم باي هدنه بل اعلن
بعضهم هذا الامر صراحه لم يتغير اي شيء
لقد استمر القذف على مواقعنا واستمرت
محاولات التقدم والنجوم من قبل القوات
المعاديه ستذكر هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
عدد مرات القصر وتفاصيل الهجمات التي تمت
خلال ما يسمى وقفه اطلاق النار يمكننا
القول انهم توقفوا عن اطلاق النار لفتارات
بسيطه فقط لا يمكن تصديق روسيا انها تكذب
باستمرار
هذا ما قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
زابارودجيا ان القوات الروسيه اقدمت خلال
ساعه ال 24 الماضيه على قصف البنيه
التحتيه في اثنتي عشره منطقه وبلده في
المقاطعه في المقاطعات الجنوبيه وفي
زباروتيا ايضا قال المتحدث باسم هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه
تواصل محاولتها اجبار سكان المقاطعه على
استخراج جوازات سفر الروسيه
والجسديه على السكان المدنيين في الاراضي
المحتله في مدينه
الاحتلال الروسيه حوالي ثلاثه الاف عمل من
محطه زباروجيا للطاقه النوويه على الحصول
على جوازات السفر الروسيه تم اخراج العمله
الاوكرانيه من التداول في المدينه من خلال
تهديد رجال الاعمال بالغرامات ومصادره
الممتلكات وازداد عدد المباني السكنيه
التي استولى عليها المحتلون بعد ان هاجرها
سكانها بشكل كبير